let's get ready to talk some money david
let's do it i already got people in the
comments uh that want me to become a
millionaire earlier than the hundredth
episode uh they're supposed to invest in
uh certain coins i'm writing all this
down guys
your knowledge your knowledge curve when
money is
exponential growth right now oh
absolutely exponential growth absolutely
i could fire away things that you just
bang i didn't know what that was boom
bing bing bitcoin yeah the roi here's
what's going on index funds stock market
budgeting 50 30 20 80 20 well you didn't
know about any of this i don't know
about any other numbers you were just
going through life loosey goosey stuff
swapping the card swiping the card
ready to be a billionaire all right
let's get ready to talk some money thank
you guys for being here let's talk money
um
this first segment that we're going to
talk about isn't so much
your money
it's more your behavior in order to
make that money all right so sometimes
the best way to make money is to change
your behavior or your antics in some
case so it's not always about making the
right investment that's going to make
you rich sometimes it's acting
the right way
some people just don't know how to act
right um change attitude change your
attitude change your lifestyle so that's
what this first story is going to talk
about right here there are certain
undeniable characteristics
undeniable that separate the great ones
from just the average joes okay we all
saw the movie dodgeball somehow the
average joe's
you know won the dodgeball contest
that's not going to happen in real life
just so you know that was a movie what
was the
gym the cobra who was it the cobra guys
globo gym globo gym yeah yeah the
reality is you want to be financially
you want to be global gym without the
you know put the on the
side but you do want to be healthy
wealthy happy fit at nice locations you
don't want to be necessarily working out
at average joe's gym however there are
certain characteristics undeniable
characteristics david that separate the
great ones from the average ones so here
are the five ways five ways to become a
top former
performer
at your company here are the top ways to
become a top performer at your company
and this is
um
across all sectors you might say i'm in
real estate this doesn't apply to me i'm
in production world i'm a lawyer this
doesn't reply no no i'm a doc everything
yeah everything sales sales sales
especially so if you're an entrepreneur
you've got sales for sure here are the
top five ways to become a performer top
performer at your company numero
uno
number one for my non-spanish speakers
is
you have to be curious i was curious
about spanish in school there you go
there was you have to be curious aka you
actually have to give up what like you
have to be like oh man tell me more
about this all right i didn't really
sure about that but you know i was
unsure but tell me more tell me more i
got to ask you what i always say the
best thing with sales is asking
questions
everyone around you is not like and
they'll let you know all right dude
you've asked
you're allowed a lot mid of questions
today but for the most part if you're
the new person at your company or you've
been there for a while asking questions
giving a
will separate yeah you from the people
are just kind of there to do a job right
and speaking of that
you know every job has a job description
here are the jobs description
now that's the basic that's entry level
all right these are my things but if you
actually want to do more
than what your job description is right
that's also a form of being curious how
can i help more what more can i do what
more value can i bring you know what
it's lacking over here i was wondering
why this um what this production over
here that we're doing over here is
really the views are down on this or the
business account is down on this so
maybe there's something like those types
of questions that curiosity
only benefits you that's number one all
right so ask questions like i always say
you have to actually
give
uh
what you have to you have to have me now
if you don't have interest in what
you're doing we've all been there yeah
you don't have interest in what you're
doing you're kind of lollygagging you
don't really want to be there that's not
where you want to be long-term if you
have major interest in your major
curiosity of what you're doing boom
that's step number one one attribute
give a level that's the go up give
a level has to go up i love that
that's david right there number two
you have to be a sponge
um
there's a lot of spongebob square bands
out there you know fans out there you're
a big spongebob fan yes i do uh indulge
in the spongebob quotes you gotta soak
it in mmm you gotta be a sponge you
gotta
i need soak in the knowledge so a lot of
times you're gonna get hired
whatever job or if you've been on your
job for a little while they're going to
say do this do this do this or this you
need to soak it in
learn learn on the job and be a quick
learner
that's the way three months six months
in boom all right now i'm in i'm in
charge of this whole thing yeah that
ties in with give a level your
level goes up the faster you soak things
up the faster you see what's going on
here you see you give a
you're curious you care all of a sudden
you're soaking knowledge in yeah you're
next you're an expert you're becoming a
student of the game right your knowledge
goes up your expertise goes up now
you're somebody now you're becoming an
expert at what you do in less than a
year what's the because you give a
you're curious
and you're soaking it in right so
what's step three well get there
so
step three while you're being curious
and while you're soaking it all in
you have to be able to take feedback
this is the hard part this is where this
is where people's feelings
get hurt
you're on the job you care you want to
be there
and um
you know you're soaking it in you're
improving you're helping the team or so
you think and now it's time for your
six-month review
or now it's time for an annual review
and people tell you
you know well here's some feedback for
you it might not even be a review might
just be some feedback on something
you're working on random day this will
this is what separates emotionally the
good from the great because regular
people are not going to be able to
respond well to feedback especially bad
feedback obviously everyone hey great
job cool cool cool but
there's also if everyone tells you
you're doing a great job and they don't
tell you what to improve you'll never
improve right that's something else to
think about
but
feedback
is at the very foundation of every
relationship
whether it's business whether it's you
know boyfriend and girlfriend marital
relationships with friendships being
able to take feedback hey by the way um
you snore like crazy when you sleep i
can't stand it oh i didn't know hey
by the way your desk area is an absolute
nightmare messy as hell
your work is great but you're a slob
okay some feedback right there um by the
way you're late you're five minutes late
to every business meeting this is a
horrible look what are you gonna do
about it but i'm awesome i'm the number
one sales person are you are you open to
feedback that's a question that actually
pbd sometimes uses are you open to
feedback who the hell says no no i'm not
open
no yeah of course not open to any
feedback whatsoever
so this is what separates the top
performers
from just your average joes that we're
talking about is the way that they react
to feedback we all know people that just
can't take
you know can't take it when somebody
just
essentially assault insults them
it's logical and hey man let me just
so you know jeff bezos had a quote he
says you know listen and be open
right
but
they can tell you
you know what to do but they can't tell
you
who you are
does that make sense
because the action that they're
they're referring to when they're giving
you feedback it's just about your job
it's not about you as a person
necessarily right yeah we had kenny
valencia here in the comments saying
constructive criticism is so important
don't take it personally exactly
there it is kenny for the w for the win
constructive criticism that's feedback
yeah so sometimes it can hurt we get it
you know pbd
basically when i talked about being five
minutes late to a meeting
that's me
pbd on the 100th episode he's like dude
you're you're 20 minutes late i know i
had a thing going on unacceptable i had
to own it i felt like in that
meeting
but you know we talked it out he
understood why but
no excuses that's my that's my bet yeah
right you have to be open for feedback
it's not all good i get a lot of good
feedback believe me i've got some hate
on pbd podcast all good i'm open to
feedback it i it might change what i do
but it's not going to change who i am
right does that make sense 100 okay
number four number four um
you have to be a double
threat what am i talking about here
double threat you gotta be gotta both
ways shout out to mario aguilar started
interrupting something he says all the
time know enough to be dangerous
so that's like yeah double threat at
least if this is where you're going with
it just maybe i am no enough to be
dangerous no in every field well this is
this is kind of like that but this is
this is
meeting you in the middle there
when i talk about being a double threat
you need to be able to grind
independently like not have someone
holding your hand just like hey here's
your project go get them bro boom i'm
off to the races cool i'm grinding but
you also
have to be able to work well with others
aka play well with others so
part one is you don't need any hand
holding you need minimal guidance you
don't need to tell anybody looking over
your shoulder telling you what to do yo
i got this we're good number two is all
right huddle up team meeting this is
what i need everybody to do if you can
be both you are very valuable to your
company
very valuable i could do it on my own
i'm good i got this you know give me a
project i'll be done with it by the end
of the day end of the week cool or hey
team meeting everybody circle up i'm
running the meeting now we're i'm
playing well without if you can do both
some people only can do one hey look
just get my project i'm gonna just you
know like a lot of the editors maybe
here at valuetainment or anywhere
there's a lot of introverts maybe that
can work independently a lot of
extroverts work with hey what's up come
on in
but to be able to
to balance both being an introverted
extrovert working well with others and
working independently
damn your stock just went up mm-hmm
threat double threat yeah 100 the lone
wolf or the or the team leader oh
i like see this is the insight that
we're waiting on david the lone wolf
and my wolf pack became two
and then
you showed up doug and i knew
our wolf pack became three fantastic
double threat right there and last but
not least and this probably is the most
important because if you actually want
to scale a company and take things to
the next level
you have to empower the people around
you empowered to the people is what i'm
talking about right here this is the
most critical why because
the most important title that you could
ever possibly have is not founder is not
ceo it's not coach it's not player it's
leader
yeah if you lead others
man sky's the limit and if you can groom
talent that we talked about hey let's
groom talent here like pbd you brought
me on he's like all right i i want to i
want to do a media company the media
company can't be pbd company it's
valuetainment all right so if i'm gonna
have a media company i need to have
other talent all right let me bring it
adam he knows his stuff about personal
finance pop culture boom let me bring in
the biz doc he's bringing in capital and
investment that's his thing danielle
dimartino booth she's bringing in
economics doing her thing lovely lady
let's bring in gerard boom he's politics
let's bring in phil heath he's got
you're collaborating you're bringing in
others you're playing well with others
and you're empowering your people uh
nothing is more important than being a
leader so david you are now
becoming kind of a leader around here
how does it feel because as i'm saying
this i'm thinking
all right what are people number one if
you're in the audience you should be
saying
i always try to give my the audience a
challenge it's this isn't this is
interactive stuff there's a reason that
we're doing this live there's a reason
that we're looking at your comments
there's a reason that i ask questions is
so you
whoever it is pick a name who is it lee
there he is louis alpha you're thinking
yourself all right cool i'm here to
learn i'm here to be entertained but
when saz asks a question and says hey of
these five things where can i improve
like me i'm curious as hell i'm
constantly asking questions people tell
me dude enough of the questions number
two love being a sponge i'm around pbd
around smart people i'm asking questions
i give up i'm soaking it all in number
three taking feedback not easy to do
not easy to do but i take it i
understand it not emotional i'm
definitely more logical than emotional
these days but sometimes the emotions
get the best of us number four for sure
for sure for sure i'm a double threat
are you
i can grind i could go my office three
hours cool get my done or boom now
it's time for time for a team meeting
play well with others so where are you
out on that one and number five
empower the people this is something
that i'm working on right now trying to
become a better leader trying to empower
others around me so there's other
leaders grooming talent um
here's what i'll say on this these
things yeah it's a listicle have five
things to be a better employee five
things they make it seem so simple
because oftentimes it kind of is
this is some basic stuff but it all it
all starts with that first that curious
and give a level yes
you don't care if you're just going in
nine to five let me just knock it off
like if if
your job becomes a thing where it's like
an obstacle and you just have to do it
and then you can live your life that's
after five mm-hmm and you're gonna be
miserable that's how you end up like ugh
pat calls it the 459 club it's 4.59 can
we dude i see you david you're here
you're here until 8 o'clock 9 o'clock at
night yeah why because you give a
right or mario will beat you maybe i
mean that's not
that's not but but no like because you
give a that's important in my job
that i you know my financial career that
i've been at me being here i've always
had a give a factor do you know
those people who's like i don't really
care whatever whatever bro
yeah that only gets you
so far at some point you need to give a
help now if you can't get ahead
if you're like you know what i'm
grinding i'm hustling you know i'm
trying to make the money i'm trying to
improve i got the career
um
maybe you're not doing one of these five
things
maybe look in the mirror and say you
know what
i really don't play well with others
i hate people
or about i hate the people i work with
maybe that's something you need to prove
upon i don't know yeah because if you're
actually doing these things consistently
that's the key consistently right
because you're doing it it's not just
one day it's day in and day out year
after year after there's no way you can
lose absolutely not this is this is
again i started this topic what this
isn't money advice this is career advice
this is how you can make
yourself a better
person to the company
to grow top performer of the company
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken